okay so thanks to the organizers for
having me at this workshop I'm really
excited to be here so I'm going to tell
you about interaction based methods for
uncovering genes that are functionally
important in cancers and this is joint
work with Dario Garcia and Boris love
her stuff so those of you who know me
know that we've been thinking about
protein networks for a decade or more so
our work is driven by the observation
that cells function on the basis of
various types of molecular and macro
molecular interactions these can be
interactions amongst proteins or
proteins and small molecules proteins
and DNA proteins and RNA and other types
of interactions as well so if we want to
understand how any cell works whether it
is a normal healthy cell within our body
or a diseased cell we've got to have
some sense about the underlying networks
and of course this is only amplified
when you think about things that the
organism level because these
interactions within cells you have cells
that interact with each other to form
tissues organs and and organisms so as a
result of this my group has been
developing methods over the years for
kind of two complementary problems on
the one hand we developed computational
methods for predicting various types of
interactions specifically various types
of protein interactions whether it's
protein DNA interactions protein protein
interactions or protein small molecule
interactions and on the other side we've
been developing a variety of methods for
trying to analyze the large-scale
interaction networks that have emerged
from high-throughput studies when we
think about trying to develop methods
for predicting interactions we often
take a structural point of view so can
we leverage information about protein
structure to make predictions about
interactions or interaction specificity
and on the other hand when we develop
methods for analyzing protein
interaction networks
we often take graph theoretic views and
so this sort of dichotomy on the one
hand between structure and interactions
has driven my work and it also kind of
frame the talk I'm giving you today so
often in the world of network biology
when you think about a network you think
about a single network for an organ
organism and this is sort of been
traditional because of the type of data
that's there but of course networks are
dynamic entities even across different
cell types within the body you have
different underlying networks but this
is especially true when you look across
individuals and so we have become
interested in the last few years in
trying to develop methods for uncovering
how various types of networks vary and
also for analyzing this variation across
networks so if you look at humans we of
course are vastly different whether on
the slider or in this room and it's
really the networks that underlie us in
particular regulatory networks in this
case that drive the phenotypic change
and so this is how I got into interested
in thinking about cancer genomics so as
we've already heard about this morning
there have been large scale efforts to
sequence the genomes of individuals
cancers and through the types of
algorithms we heard about in the first
talk we've uncovered the alterations
that are found in in the tumors versus
the genomes that are inherited and this
has been done across large numbers of
individuals and the interpretation can
sometimes be done at then the population
level so there are many interesting
questions I know we'll hear a lot about
them this week that you can try to
answer with this type of data but I was
just going to focus on one type of goal
which is which of the numerous mutated
genes so looking just at mutations
single nucleotide variations within
genes that encode proteins play a role
in either
through initiation or progression so
trying to develop methods that take
protein networks and protein
interactions into mind to try to uncover
which of the many altered genes are the
ones that are really important for for
cancer so I'm going to tell you about
two projects and the first one is joint
work with Dario Garrity who's now on the
faculty at Nebraska and here we're gonna
take a structural perspective and we're
gonna focus on mutations that affect
protein interactions in cancers so I
think it goes without saying but I'll
say it anyway that mutations that affect
protein interactions are critical so if
we look at a gene that encodes a protein
not all mutations are created equal
those that interact with the
functionally relevant molecule of the
protein are going to be more important
so this could be what the the residues
that interact with small molecules this
could be residues that are in a protein
protein interface or this could be
residues that are in contact with DNA
amongst others and so our work begins
with the idea that disrupted protein
interactions can play a role in acquired
disorders such as cancers and of course
also in in in inherited disorders so
with this in mind we wanted to try to
develop a pipeline that would identify
residues that take part in interactions
and so what we did was we looked at
variance with respect to some reference
sequence we map these variants on to the
reference sequences and then for each
reference sequence we compared it to
other sequences for which structures had
already been determined if two sequences
are similar they tend to have the same
structure so if we found another
sequence with which it had sequence
identity greater than 60% then we used
its structure as a template for this
sequence so we required a sequence
similarity of 60% we use this great
resource that's called by OLAP which has
about 60,000 structures in it and this
is partly curated database we're binding
residues have been identified so within
a protein structure residues that
interact with either nucleic acids small
molecules ions or peptides have been
identified so once we found a sequence
that's similar to some structure in this
database we can transfer information
about which residues are the ones that
are taking part in binding interfaces so
this type of pipeline is automated and
you can download it it can bind on
Princeton edu and I wanted to say that
with this structural approach this is
actually fairly conservative with
respect to how much sequence identity is
required we can at current model about
22 percent of human protein so it's not
modeling all the human protein but
aspects of it so now we have this
pipeline we can start asking some
interesting questions so for example we
can just look across healthy populations
and look at the snips that are found
across those populations and so we can
look at this in aggregate and that's
what we'll do to start with so we can
ask how many sites have structural
information so I said 20% of the
proteins and then the subset of the
residues within these proteins how many
of these sites are polymorphic how many
of these sites are involved in binding
using the pipeline that I just described
to you and then how many of these
binding residues are polymorphic and so
here we're just going to consider
missense mutations because we're taking
this in mind with respect to protein
structures so what we found is if you
look at the total number of sites that
have have snips you get some number and
you can make a theoretical distribution
that comes from this data and that's
just a hyper geometric distribution
and what you observe clearly is in
aggregate polymorphic sites across
humans tend to avoid binding binding
residues so binding residues tend not to
be turn out to vary across individuals
now now that's not the case for each
individual type of protein so for
example some proteins their functions
depend on their variations so
immunological proteins for example you
would see a lot of variation we're just
an aggregate this is true okay so then
we can say now what happens when you
look across disease populations and so
here we looked at cancer missense
mutations here across eight TCGA cancer
types and again we ask the same question
if we look at binding sites how many of
the residues have some mutation found
within them across the sample of
patients and in this case we actually
see the opposite trend so that we see
that cancer missense mutations are
actually enriched in binding sites as
compared to what you would expect by
chance alone you can repeat this
exercise instead of looking at missense
mutations by looking at synonymous
mutations instead if you have a
synonymous mutation you're not changing
the amino acid and so you're not going
to have effect at least on the structure
and in this case across this same set of
individuals you see that there's no
enrichment of mutations in the binding
sites of these proteins so the data I
just told you about is an aggregate over
three different types of binding sites
and that included nucleic acids small
molecules and peptides but if you
separated them individually you would
see the same trends so cancer missense
mutations seem to be found
preferentially within binding sites that
are involved in nucleic acids small
molecule or peptide interactions okay so
this was an act this was an aggregate
analysis
and we wondered whether we could turn
this around and make a per gene or
protein method to try to identify genes
that are enriched in mutations in their
binding sites and I think this is an
interesting way to go because kind of
the one observation is that frequently
mutated genes that are known to be
playing a driving role in cancers seem
to by and large have been identified and
so here's a plot looking at 22 different
cancers and it has five well known
cancer players along with two controls
and you can see large numbers of
mutations across them so I think the
real challenge in this game then is in
identifying less frequently mutated
genes that play a functional role in
cancers and so we're hoping that this
structural method would be one way of
accomplishing this okay so what we did
next was look at things at a per gene or
per protein level and very simply it
works like this so you take in a gene
you identify the binding residues so
shown in black here you tally the
mutations in the gene across all your
samples and you compute some kind of
mutation binding score in this very
simple example we're just counting up
the number of times it hits a binding
residue so it's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so that's
just some score you want to know if this
score is more than you expect by chance
so you can permute all the mutations
across the protein sequence this
randomized data you can compute a
mutation binding score you can repeat
this numerous times to build a
distribution and then you can get a
p-value for this binding score now this
is the outline of what we do I just
wanted to say that in fact we take
structure more into account than this
and so when considering binding residues
we actually consider the fraction of of
heavy atoms that are in contact with the
ligand but the overall outline is as
follows so now we have a method for
looking at things that appear
Jeane way that tries to figure out
whether binding sites are enriched in
mutations so next we can order our genes
based on how significant their p-values
are and we can try to do some assessment
so if we did that where we ordered the
the genes based on p-value we can ask
whether known cancer genes are enriched
in the set with the most significant
p-values or not and in fact that's what
we observe so if we use the method I
just outlined with missense mutations as
we look at smaller and smaller p-values
we see a larger enrichment in these
known cancer genes we can repeat that
process I'm just focusing on synonymous
mutations again these don't affect
protein structure and so you here see
this flatter distribution so you don't
see the enrichment so as an example this
is the type of thing you might see with
our pipeline so here's the protein Dicer
actually a domain of it this protein as
most of you know is involved in micro
RNA processing when you look at
endometrial cancer and glioblastoma what
you observe is that there are a number
of mutations that you see that are
involved in binding to a magnesium that
are involved in binding magnesium and
these mutations take this negatively
charged amino acid amino acids glutamic
acid glutamic acid and aspartic acid and
change them to amino acids that aren't
negatively charged and these this
negatively charged Valley is required
for catalytic activity so it gives you
perhaps a functional way in which these
mutations are affecting the functioning
of these proteins across these cancers
as you can see there are other mutations
as well those are shown in blue and
those are the ones that are not involved
in binding but these mutations are
enriched you can do this type of
analysis across cancers individually
and what we've shown here is a heat plot
where once you do an FDR correction you
identify a number of genes that are
significant across these eight different
cancer types and in red are genes these
are the genes and in red are genes that
are known cancer genes and what you can
see is many of these known cancer genes
are actually enriched in mutations and
their interaction interfaces many of
these genes have these mutations across
cancer types but they're also other
genes that have more cancer specific
patterns okay so to kind of summarize
this section of what I was doing I
wanted to say again that mutations
within protein binding sites are under
enriched across healthy individuals and
they tend to be over enriched in
aggregate across cancers and so this
leads to a method that's based on the
interaction interface for predicting
genes that are functionally important in
cancers and we would hope perhaps in
other diseases we're doing a lot of
ongoing work in this area and in
particular we're trying to extend the
applicability of this approach via
predicted binding sites as well as
protein domain information so I think
actually this is a very promising way to
go it turns out that 60% of human
proteins contain at least one
interaction domain so we're going to
have information about which of its
residues interact with ligands and I
think we can push the plic ability of
our method by incorporating this other
type of information
okay so for the second part of my talk I
went into and this is joint work with
borislav Hurst off with some input from
my colleague Bernard Giselle so in this
part of the talk I wanted to talk about
cancer mutations in the context of
protein interaction networks so very
soon after the first large-scale protein
internet interaction networks were
determined it became clear that these
networks had a lot of structure within
them so these networks have this modular
structure and proteins that take part in
the same complexes or biological
processes or biological pathways tend to
be proximal in networks so you know I
think it's natural to think about
interpreting the mutations that you see
across cancers or across other disease
types in the context of these networks
and so the goal with this type of work
putting together mutational information
with network information would be to
identify groups of genes or proteins
that together are mutated across
individuals of course this is something
that's been proposed many years ago in a
different context before cancer so I
think we're dead worked on it with
disease genes with Mendelian diseases
been has worked on similar things with
respect to cancers so this is this idea
of interpreting mutations in the context
of networks is clearly a natural one and
I think it's also clear why it would be
especially useful in cancers because in
cancer so this is an example from the
glioblastoma TCGA paper they observed
that there mutated pathways so three
examples are given here but when you
look across the cohort of patients you
find that different mutations within
these pathways are found in different
patients and so these are current
different patterns as we heard about in
the last talk you can have rules for
example or you can have trends of mutual
exclusivity exclusivity
so one key observation is that there are
some genes that may be mutated in
smaller fractions of the patients than
others okay so looking at mutations
within within the context of networks
gives you a way to try to think about
things at the level of pathways instead
of individual genes but may allow you to
identify genes that play functionally
important roles even though they're not
perturbed across many cancer types
so the rough framework that we're
thinking about is in this toy example is
that you have a toy network and you have
a set of individuals and you have a set
of genes that are found to be mutated
across these individuals so what we do
is we annotate each gene or protein with
the individual where that gene is found
to be mutated in so for example this
gene is found to be mutated in patient
one patient two and patient three and
our simple goal would be look to look
for a small connected component that
covers most of these patients so that
these this small connected component
shown in red the the the patients would
tend to have a mutation in one of these
genes and the idea is that these small
connected components then correspond to
these shared pathways that might be
perturbed across patients now I wanted
to say this of course is related to
previous work I think the first that I
know of is you let's see it's you let's
see it at L so from Ron's group but
there's also been work from Teresa's
group and Mainland Co u Turks group
amongst others so it's our formulation
is somewhat different and so let me talk
to you a little bit about the
formulation so in our case we wanted to
take a trade-off between the size of the
subgraph that you're building and the
overall number of patients that are
covered we don't ultimately require that
all patients be covered
so if you choose all the proteins in
your protein protein interaction Network
you're going to get high coverage of
patients are you're gonna cover all of
them or at least all them that could be
covered by the network but you're not
going to be uncovering anything causal
or that that even less than cause like
that plays a functional role in these
cancers on the other hand may be better
you can have fewer nodes in your graph
on the bad side maybe you're going to
explain fewer of your patient samples
but your connected component is more
likely to consist of genes that are
functionally related to each other so
the way we formulate this problem is to
try to find a connected subgraph G prime
of G that minimizes this objective
function which consists of two parts one
is a component that corresponds to the
fraction of patients that are uncovered
that is the graph doesn't contain a gene
in which it has a mutation in and the
other is some measure of the size of the
subgraph we don't know how important
these two pieces are and so we have this
alpha parameter that kind of controls
the trade-off and though I won't talk
about it today I'll just say that you
can solve this exactly with integer
linear programming the only trick you
have to be careful of is that you need
to make sure that your solution
maintains a connected subgraph but you
can use different techniques to ensure
that in any case you can solve this
exactly but it but it is time consuming
so instead we use a heuristic which I'll
touch a simple heuristic which I'll tell
you about next but I wanted to talk a
little bit about the size of the graph
so a very simple measure of the size of
a graph would simply be the number of
nodes so the number of proteins that
take part in your sub graph this has the
advantage of being simple and intuitive
but it has one major disadvantage which
is longer genes on average will have a
they're going to require more mutations
and so that's not really a good measure
to use and so we use a measure of size
that's based
on the weight where this weight
penalizes the gene for being longer and
then rewards the gene for having more
mutations so we trade off here lengths
and the number of mutation so this is
the inverse of the mutation rate and
then the size of the sub graph simply
sums over these weights so the heuristic
that we use now to to try to find this
connected subgraph that minimizes this
objective function where you're trying
to cover patients and also keep your
graph small is we start off by picking a
node greedily and we add it to the sub
graph that we're building and then we
look over all the neighbors of the sub
graph that we have and we add to the sub
graph the node that improves the
objective function the most so we
actually allow hops of length two and
that's why you may end up adding two
nodes instead of one and then you just
repeat this and you stop once there are
no more proteins that improve the
objective we've tested the exact
optimization on small networks and so it
has similar performance to the exact
exact optimization but obviously it's
it's much faster so what I haven't said
now is I have these two things I'm
trying to trade off and I use this alpha
parameter to do the trade off how do I
actually pick this alpha so we could do
it with some kind of magic or we could
try to take a data-driven approach to do
this and that's what we do here so what
we're going to do is we're going to vary
alpha we're going to withhold a fraction
of the patients on the set that's left
the training set we're going to find G
prime using the algorithm the simple
greedy algorithm that I just described
and then using that sub graph G Prime
we're going to see how well we cover
this withheld fraction which is the
validation set with G Prime and then we
just add one kind of layer outside of it
which is in the very beginning just as a
sort of a sanity check we're going to
withhold as a test set twenty percent of
the patients and then we're going to
repeat this process I just described to
you for choosing the same the best alpha
on a training set and a validation set
and then ultimately we want to make sure
that your performance on the validation
set is similar to that on your test set
okay and I won't actually show that data
but in fact it is so this is a pretty
robust procedure so we ran this process
on various TCGA data I'm just going to
show you today results on kidney cancer
where we looked at 416 patients they had
220 that 22 mutations on average we
looked at various networks the data I'm
going to describe to you now is actually
from a high-throughput network that
consists of around 8,000 proteins and
24,500 interactions we've also looked at
larger networks like bio grid okay so
the first thing was picking an alpha and
so what we do here is we vary alpha and
small increments and we run our
heuristic procedure and we ask what
fraction of the patients are covered and
we do this on the training set and
that's shown in blue and that's what
we're writing our algorithm on and then
once we have something output we're
going to ask what fraction of patients
are covered on this validation set and
that's what's shown in red and so the
idea is is that while these two things
are close together we're having good
generalization and once these things get
apart then your overfitting on your
training set and then we also track the
number of genes in your sub Network as
you're running these different values of
alpha so in something like this you can
see that while we're at about alpha
equals 0.5 we still do pretty well when
using the training set and then in turn
with respect to coverage on both the
training set and the validation set but
when you have very large values of alpha
you get very large sub networks but you
have a big difference between the
validation set and the training set and
the validate the coverage on the
validation set doesn't improve
okay so this is how we choose alpha so
say we chose an alpha of 0.5 now to
actually use this network based approach
to try to predict the genes that we
think are most likely to pay some
functional role in either cancer
initiation or progression we do the
following so we repeat many times we
randomly hold out a fraction of the
patients we run this heuristic procedure
so this procedure already has randomness
built into it so we're not gonna get
back one solution so it doesn't make
sense to just do this once we're gonna
run this heuristic procedure and then
we're gonna rank the genes by the number
of times its output across these
multiple iterations so that gives a
purging score based on the algorithm
that we just described so now we can ask
how we do we've done different
validations but here's just an example
where we look as we consider more and
more on genes by their score we ask what
fraction of the genes are cancer census
genes and so this interaction based
method I just described is shown in blue
we can implement the same thing but not
use any network information and that's
we just are calling it the set cover
approach here and of course that's also
been used by itself to think about
disease genes and that's shown in red
and so you can see across the range of
considering more and more genes
including Network information helps and
then we can also consider other
approaches so here we've just put one of
the frequency based approaches that
smooth see but the the recent version of
music and you can see that it dominates
it as well so using this type of
interaction information is helpful you
can do other types of downstream
analysis I won't go into that but the
list of genes that you would get if you
look at those that are current at least
half of the output sub-graphs
they're enriched and known cancer
pathways they're enriched in relevant go
terms and they contain recently a newly
implicated cancer genes and with respect
to future work I think here we've really
just considered missense mutations in
protein coding regions
trying to extend this framework to
integrate other type of perturbations is
where we'd like to go and to stop I told
you about two projects a structure based
project related to interaction
interfaces and a network based project
relating to thinking about we take two
mutations in the context of networks
there are known drivers that are
infrequent or that are infrequent yes so
we also I didn't show that but we also
get genes for example that aren't that a
very low mutation counts sometimes that
also aren't aren't mutated so or that
and some that are known to be drivers
and other cancers but aren't mutated in
in the cancer that we're looking at
so first question who are you well
that's what this alpha parameter is for
so we have this alpha parameter that
says that that lets you cover fewer
patients because as you're saying you
really might over fit and so a key part
of the procedure is actually picking the
alpha so that you ensure that you're not
overfitting and just covering patients
even though it might not be relevant you
think that the size part of this
framework could be improved I think
often I think that's something that we
could think about in the future as well
I think what we're doing now which is
considering mutation rate is a
reasonable way to proceed but perhaps
you want to think about not just the
number of genes that are in your network
but also things like the density of the
subgraph that's induced or things like
that
yeah yeah so I don't think what I don't
think we've measured that directly I
mean certainly that at the top of the
list there's not a lot of change in
terms of and the genes that are output
what what changes is later later on and
that's why we run it multiple times and
we actually use that to score the genes
okay let's thank once again